il tracte tous les week-ends devant les
commerces l'équipe de la liste ensemble
agissons pour wii en cours menée par
rodolphe barry considère ce rendez-vous
comme incontournable pour venir à la
rencontre des habitants
ça se passe plutôt bien on a un bon
accueil de la part des deux ans courtois
donc tout le monde nous prendre nos
tracts et puis certains s'arrêtent pour
échanger globalement franchement là on a
vraiment un très très bon accueil
une liste sans étiquette et indépendante
d'anciens membres de la majorité ont été
séduits notamment par la volonté de
faire des efforts pour la jeunesse et la
démographie locale
je crois qu'aujourd'hui tous les
citoyens sont en attente justement de sa
d'avoir une place dans la vie de leur
ville dans la vie de la société et plus
que ce soit 2,3 personnes qui décident
pour eux une démocratie locale avec la
volonté de créer des conseils de
quartier mais aussi un accent mis sur le
développement durable avec un maire
adjoint dédié et l'élaboration ou d'éco
quartier enfin le programme qui sera
bientôt dévoilée souhaite mettre
l'accent sur la tranquillité publique
pour nous la tranquillité publique ça
commence par la prévention c'est
incontournable prévention mais aussi
renforcement du nombre de caméras de
vidéoprotection et renforcement aussi du
nombre de policiers municipaux
plusieurs mouvements politiques de
centre droit lui ont apporté son soutien
non demandées mais acceptée par le
candidat qui ne les affiche sera
cependant pas dans ses tracts dans la
commune de vie en cours quatre autres
listes sont déclarés à ce jour